this is step number two on how to read
books for learning foreign languages now
that you have got your favorite book or
a book that you're interesting in and
which is not at a too difficult level
the next step is actually to decide
before and the week before a time slots
for your reading sessions because we
always complain about the fact we don't
have time but actually it's about making
the time so for example just choose 30
minutes at night or 30 minutes in the
morning whenever you feel fresh to
dedicate to reading the book this is
really important tip number two is that
you have to find a good position to read
a book now if you're reading the book
you can you can read by sitting down but
sitting down on a desk like I'm doing
right now feels like homework right so
maybe you can find something like just
sitting on a couch or even lying on the
bed this is really important because the
position of your body really influences
the way you pay attention to what you're
actually doing and the third tip is to
choose a specific number of pages that
you want to cover every day so your for
example 20 or 30 and so if you for
example established 30 minutes a day
then in these 30 minutes maybe you will
able to cover 15 pages the number of
pages and the number of minutes are
going to compensate each other and the
great thing about this is that you're
going to create a habit your brain is
going to stick to thank you for watching